salut filmsactu fan de bande annonce
aujourd'hui je tombe à lens 3 au visage
parlera d'amour et d'amitié en anglais
puisqu'on se fera we are your friends
alfred babo savoir et love et didier
bonne anse la première on a donc quatre
mecs passionné par l'organisation de
soirées un peu moins par leurs études un
lait qui veulent vivre leur rêve de 10
dollars
tout ça pour choper des meufs moi je
suis sur youtube mais ça marche pas du
tout si le roi de la fredzone mais vaut
mieux être franson et quand on freine
des unes friend and friends and friends
du budget en frêne sacre à regarder
je suis certain que pendant cette bande
annonce vous regardiez ce une fenêtre
n'était pas ouverte un oui car je suis
mince ma mère et je lis dans vos pensées
mais le tabac c'est le champion lucian
freud vous de ce calibre est plus chez
nous par hasard la dernière
bande-annonce est plus légère et parle
d'un sujet lourd
les plans à 3,9 pas ce genre de plan à
trois saint-etienne non vous allez le
voir dans la bande-annonce est plutôt
jour là
ah je le verrais bien à quatre mois avec
un mec qui fait la guitare au pied du
lit
oui
le réalisateur de love gaspar noé a
encore fait fort après irréversible
appelle moi papa benoît pop voilà bon
c'est trois mandats non j'espère que ça
vous a plu continuer à regarder sur
filmsactu et nous on se retrouve bientôt
dans votre ordinateur
oh non